je voudrais qu'on se parle de l'iPhone
14 faut-il acheter l'iPhone 14 ou
faut-il plutôt aller sur l'iPhone 13 les
deux sont très proches beaucoup trop
proche il y a des tarifs qui se tiennent
dans un mouchoir de poche enfin un
mouchoir un peu élevé en prison donc la
question à savoir c'est si je veux
acheter un nouvel iPhone et que je n'ai
pas un iPhone récent si vous avez un
iPhone 13 n'est pas si vous avez un
iPhone 12 je pense pas que ça va
réellement le coup si vous avez un
smartphone Android ou si vous avez
vraiment veiller iPhone faut-il choisir
l'iPhone 13 ou l'iPhone 14 est-ce qu'on
va voir ici
[Musique]
on va commencer par le commencement sur
le site d'Apple iPhone 13 iPhone 14
l'iPhone 13 coûte 909 € aujourd'hui en
tarif neufs et si vous voulez le dernier
modèle donc la génération d'après la
dernière génération l'iPhone 14 1019
euros ça veut dire qu'on a un écart de
110 euros entre ces deux iPhone moi je
trouve ça dingue regardez je vous montre
ça veut dire qu'ici je vais avoir mon
iphone 13 et ici j'ai mon iphone 14 là
1019 euros 909 euros là on se parle de
tarif neuf ça veut dire que j'ai un
différentiel de 110 euros ça veut dire
que le différentiel c'est à peu près 10%
du tarif de l'iPhone 14 j'ai beaucoup de
mal à comprendre que le tarif du modèle
de l'année dernière soit exactement le
même et n'est pas bougé 909 €, il y a eu
une augmentation au prix de l'iPhone 14
alors attendez je vous arrête tout de
suite ça me paraît logique que le prix
des iPhone augmente on est dans une
période d'inflation une période de crise
c'est pas évident je crois pas qu'Apple
cherche à augmenter ses marches et à
gagner plus d'argent je pense qu'Apple
cherche plutôt à préserver ses marges et
à gagner autant d'argent en tout cas pas
en gagner moins et surtout pas en perdre
donc ça me paraît logique aujourd'hui vu
la crise que les tarifs des iPhone
augmente d'autant plus que si vous
regardez aux US est beaucoup moins cher
on a beaucoup de taxes ici en Europe
passons un peu l'histoire je voudrais
qu'on se penche un petit peu du côté
déjà des design des iPhone parce que si
vous regardez l'iPhone 13 versus
l'iPhone 14 c'est la même chose ils ont
exactement la même tête c'est à dire que
si on veut vraiment profiter de
l'innovation qui est intéressante d'un
point de vue esthétique cette année
c'est à dire dynamic Aylan c'est-à-dire
en fait une encoche un peu moins haute
bon il y a toujours un trou il y a
toujours cette espèce de grosse bulles
au centre elle est là on l'aime on
l'aime pas elle est en tout cas mais bon
il y a un travail esthétique qui a été
fait du point de vue d'Apple qu'on
l'aime ou qu'on ne l'aime pas par contre
entre l'iPhone 13 et l'iPhone 14 c'est
exactement la même chose qu'est-ce qui
va changer les couleurs alors j'ai un
petit verre j'ai un petit bleu je vais
avoir du mauve je vais avoir la couleur
minuit un petit clair et un petit rouge
voilà même le rouge est un peu différent
et mise à part cette différence de
couleur et bien j'ai la même chose le
même smartphone en tout cas d'un point
de vue extérieur parce que d'un point de
vue intérieur c'est pas réellement ça
Apple nous a dit on a retravaillé le
design intérieur de notre iPhone pour
apporter quoi notamment une meilleure
dissipation thermique ça veut dire que
l'iPhone 14 je ferai moins par rapport à
l'iPhone 13 sur des longues parties de
jeux notamment et puis ce qui vous parle
également d'un design intérieur qui est
différent ils sont venus augmenter un
peu la batterie une batterie ça prend un
peu plus de place forcément quand on
l'augmente on s'en doutera donc on va
voir une meilleure autonomie sur
l'iPhone 14 par rapport à l'iPhone 13
pour autant est-ce que ça suffira à
venir justifier la différence pour moi
la réponse est non alors continuons à
regarder il y a d'autres choses qui vont
être intéressantes on voit qu'on a
exactement la même taille d'écran entre
l'iPhone 14 et l'iPhone 13 une
différence qui peut être intéressante
c'est la détection d'accident qui arrive
pour la première fois en tout cas sur
les iPhone la détection d'accident d'un
point de vue purement matériel c'est
quoi le gain c'est un meilleur gyroscope
et un meilleur accéléromètre en tout cas
ça permettra de vraiment détecter les
accidents et après c'est le logiciels
qui va calculer ça directement est-ce
que pour autant ça suffira à venir
justifier la différence de prix pour moi
la réponse reste non alors continue on
nous le marque au niveau de l'appareil
photo on a un double appareil photo sauf
que au niveau de l'iPhone 14 il est
avancé veut dire quoi avancé en fait
vous avez une meilleure ouverture mais
ça vous le verrez un peu plus loin c'est
à dire qu'ici on vient ouvrir AF 1.5 ça
sera un peu mieux condition de faible
luminosité au niveau de l'iPhone 14 tout
en sachant qu'ici on a quand même pas le
capteur de 48 mégapixels qu'on a sur les
versions professionnelles donc bon voilà
la caméra trouveps aussi un peu
améliorée avec une mise au point
automatique bon ok pas de souci
là-dessus mais on a la le bus et ça je
trouve ça hyper déconnant et quand les
rumeurs en parlaient j'ai dit non mais
c'est pas possible il plaisante c'est
pas possible qu'on ait la même puce
alors on va vous dire on est à la même
puce mais elle a un peu meilleure
pourquoi parce que vous avez un cœur de
plus au niveau du GPU j'ai pas eu c'est
ce qui va gérer la partie graphique
notamment pour vos jeux et pour
différents éléments mais est-ce que le
fait que on est un cœur de plus au
niveau du GPU ça va vraiment changer
l'histoire en sachant que c'est la même
puce pour moi la réponse est non alors
continuons face Idy ok pas de différence
au niveau des matériaux les mêmes
capacités de stockage la même dalle
exactement la même dalle ici rien ne
change alors il va être un tout petit
peu plus épais l'iPhone 14 bon je pense
que c'est peut-être la taille de la
batterie en tout cas le design intérieur
qui explique ça les appareils photos
vous voyez F 1.5 versus f1.6 bon voilà
c'est histoire de de voilà on va voir le
photonique enjoy en plus bon ok et là où
on voit quelques petites différences
c'est notamment au niveau du mode
cinématique ou au lieu de filmer en
1080p à 30 images par seconde vous
filmez en 4K HDR jusqu'à 30 images par
seconde qui utiliserait réellement le
mode cinématique qu'il y en a réellement
besoin est-ce que pour vous c'est
vraiment intéressant de mode cinématique
je suis pas convaincu c'est bien c'est
sûr je suis content
vu la différence de prix bon on continue
le mode action est arrivé sur l'iPhone
14 par rapport à l'iPhone 13 on l'avait
pas ok sur la caméra avant on va voir
une ouverture un peu plus basse donc
meilleur pour les conditions de faible
luminosité on a également le photonique
engine ici on a également les modes
cinématiques en 4 4 en images par
seconde ok on a une différence également
au niveau du Bluetooth Bluetooth 5.3
versus Bluetooth 5.0 bon ok moi le truc
qui manque il était déjà pas sur
l'iPhone 13 il est toujours pas sur
l'iPhone 14 et même sur les modèles pro
on n'a pas de Wi-Fi 6e et ça je trouve
ça extrêmement déconnant qu'aujourd'hui
on n'est pas de wifi 6 sur les iPhone
tout en sachant que les nouvelles box
sont arrivés avec du wifi 6e donc vous
avez profité de meilleurs débit à la
maison sauf que votre smartphone ne
supporte pas le wifi ce donc vous
restaurez sur le wifi 6 qui est déjà
très bien mais pour voir qu'on a des
smartphones la plus de 1000 euros on n'a
pas la dernière technologie ça j'ai du
mal à le comprendre aujourd'hui d'autant
plus que si vous prenez je sais pas moi
le dernier smartphone haut de gamme de
Samsung ils l'ont et chez Apple non donc
j'ai quand même quelques petites
différences ici je vais pouvoir venir
retrouver au niveau de mes iPhone mais
aucun qui va vraiment permettre de faire
le choix entre d'un côté 909 euros et de
l'autre côté 1019 euros alors attendez
je continue je pousse ma réflexion moi
je me dis ok attendez on se parle de
l'iPhone 13 il est sorti il y a un an
quelque chose près donc je peux me dire
où trouver d'occasion c'est vrai mais
c'est là où arrive une autre notion très
importante celle de valeur résiduelle
valeur
résiduelle et ça c'est super important
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire votre
iPhone il va pas trop de perte de valeur
ce qui fait que l'iPhone reste toujours
un produit qu'on peut revendre à un
certain prix en tirer un peu d'argent
contrairement à notre smartphone comme
des smartphones de Samsung où tu arrives
tout de suite dégringoler davantage donc
si vous achetez un iPhone vous pourrez
en tirer toujours un peu d'argent dans
un an dans deux ans et ça c'est plutôt
bien mais ça veut donc dire que si on va
regarder le marché de l'occasion je vous
emmène sur back market par exemple et
bien vous regardez les iPhone 13 j'en ai
un là qui coûte 831 euros contre 900 9
euros c'est déconnant c'est beaucoup
trop cher 831 c'est pareil 850 euros ici
vous voyez et 900 euros versus 909 euros
je trouve ça cher je trouve ça très cher
il y en a même qui vous le mettent à 909
euros enfin bref il y a des mecs qui
planent complètement et si je regarde
sur Google Shopping parce que je me dis
bon back market c'est bien mais il n'y a
pas que ça et là je regarde voyez chez
Boulanger j'ai dû recruter sur le mini
859 euros sur la Fnac là je suis ils
c'est vraiment péter un plomb ça c'est
du mini la j'en ai un pareil sur 59
euros là j'en ai un à 832 euros sur
CDiscount l'agenté un par contre à 301
je me méfierai à moins que ce soit par
un opérateur ou qui est du sponsoring
mais sinon non j'irai pas donc voyez les
iPhone reste très cher donc la question
qu'on se pose continue à se poser
faut-il venir acheter un iphone 13 ou un
iPhone 14 aujourd'hui tout de suite là
si je veux acheter un iPhone et bien je
dirais que ça dépend ça dépend de quoi
ça dépend du prix auquel vous allez
venir l'acheter parce que dans les faits
les différences entre l'iPhone 13 et
l'iPhone 14 ne sont réellement pas
significatives donc la seule chose qui
va vraiment faire la différence c'est le
prix donc il est sûr que lorsque vous
venez mettre quasiment 1000 euros voir
un peu plus de 1000 euros sur un
smartphone est-ce que ce delta de 110
euros est important il a son importance
parce que les iPhone de toute façon
n'ont pas de bloc de charge donc si vous
n'avez pas déjà un iPhone assez récent
avec un bloc de charge et bien il va
falloir en acheter un donc ça fait
rajouter un peu plus à l'addition
maintenant je me tâte voyez je me pose
la question je me dis allez j'ai 1000
balles 900 euros je fais quoi alors ça
me fait vraiment chier de vous le dire
mais je vais trancher là-dessus je vais
vous dire tant que le prix reste aux
alentours 850 euros ici voir 909 euros
venez acheter un iphone 14 pourquoi
parce que lorsque vous allez dire
revendre votre smartphone dans 6 mois un
an deux ans votre iPhone 14 vaudra plus
d'argent que votre iPhone 13 aujourd'hui
les carrés il est pas significatif mais
il va se creuser dans le temps c'est une
certitude donc vous récupérez plus
d'argent avec un iPhone 14 avec un
iPhone 13 pour moi la fiche technique
est quasiment la même quasiment
semblable les petits détails ne viennent
pas servir à justifier la différence de
prix qu'on a ici si vous trouvez un
iPhone 13 d'occasion ou en neuf à prix
casser à moins de 800 euros allez-y les
yeux fermés attention auprès d'un
vendeur français parce qu'il faut des
garanties cette fois vous avez un
problème ça peut arriver le défaut zéro
n'existe pas mais je dirais que tout va
se jouer au niveau du palier du tarif en
dessous de 800 euros je vais sur un
iPhone 13 sinon je vais sur un iPhone 14
pour autant vous ferez exactement la
même chose avec pour autant il aura
exactement le même look and feel on ne
pourra pas trop les différencier si ce
n'est au niveau du dos et comme de toute
façon vous allez vers mettre une coque
de protection on pourra pas venir les
différencier mais une fois de plus
qu'est-ce qui prévaut ici c'est l'argent
et surtout l'argent que vous n'allez pas
perdre pourquoi à cause de cette notion
importante de valeur résid voilà voilà
ce que j'en ressors aujourd'hui je me
suis vraiment creusé la tête parce que
j'ai préparé cette vidéo j'ai dit il est
évident qu'il faut pas venir acheter
l'iPhone 14 il faut venir acheter
l'iPhone 13 mais on trouve très fold
d'iPhone 13 pas trop cher ou alors
attendez encore quelques mois si vous
pouvez que l'iPhone 13 diminue en tarif
au niveau du marché de l'occasion ou du
reconditionné surtout du reconditionné
et là ça pourra devenir intéressant mais
en attendant non et si vous voulez un
bon iPhone et que vous voulez pas aimer
trop d'argent acheter un iphone 12 voilà
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires me demandez-vous très
bientôt et on continue à parler tech
bisous et surtout n'oubliez pas on se
fait le test des iPhone bientôt on va
regarder l'iPhone 14 plus quelle format
qui est plus intéressant cette année
parce que c'est pas un modèle Pro mais
on a un très grand écran c'est celui qui
a poussé en tout cas vers la porte de
sortie l'iPhone mini et puis on
regardera également les iPhone pro et on
parlera notamment de l'iPhone 14 pro max
donc abonnez-vous et actionnez la cloche
c'est pas déjà fait je vous embrasse à
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]